Hello everyone, how are you? This is Jin
from Next Level Commander and today we
have a legend that delivers the VV
experience for 300th of the price. Now,
a few weeks ago, I made a video talking
about a budget build around VV ornate. I
went through the deck list to make sure
everything is bulk. I double and triple
checked except for one minor negligence.
Now, there's been a lot of negativity
around VV lately. The price, the power,
wizards pushing it just a little too
far. And within the span of weeks, Vivv
went from one of the most beloved
characters in Final Fantasy to the
representation of everything people
disliked about this set. I also didn't
like the fact that the commander for my
budget brute costs more than the rest of
the deck. So, I went and found an
alternative. Same cost, similar stats,
and can be just as annoying for your
opponents with a day and night trigger
if you choose to constantly remind them.
Now, the more relevant text here,
though, is that as Vldrich grows, he
will reduce the cost of all your
instance and sorceries. While reducing
every spell by one or two mana is quite
significant in a storm build, I still
don't think he's able to come close to
Vive for that. But for the deck that we
brainstormed, Vdrich can definitely fill
the role. Maybe even better in some
aspects. Now, the idea is to use the
most efficient palm spells on Valdrich
to give a large temporary boost and
after that cast some massive draw spell
to refill our hand and then attack for
the win with our still enlarged
commander. Normally allin voltron decks
like this face the problem of taking
someone out of the game fast and then
doing nothing afterwards cuz you're out
of gas. It's quite an unfun play pattern
for you and the unfortunate victim. But
in the case of Valdrich or Vive, we are
refilling our hands as we kill and we
pretty much never run out of gas. Now,
let's take a quick look at the selection
of pump spells. And Valrich actually has
an advantage here because of his
ability. We want to play cards that have
at least one colorless cost because it's
always reduced. This allows us to play
the more powerful, more impactful pump
spells compared to Vivvie for the same
mana cost. But at the same time, we are
also limited by pips cuz those are not
reduced. So, we have to prioritize
spells that are low in color costs. All
right, here are some of the pump spells.
As you can see, for one extra mana, we
get a little more value. Sometimes it's
extra pump, for example, antagonize or
screaming fury. Or sometimes we get
cards like haste magic where we can
potentially play an extra card or also
you come to the null camp where it can
be a pump spell or some evasion in a
pinch. I try to prioritize the spells
that gave trample because it also serves
as evasion. Next up, we have pump spells
that are just a little bit more
complicated. No, Ancestors Aid pumps
only for two, but gives us a treasure
token, which refunds us the one mana
spent. And also cards like Rush of Blood
and Unleash Fury, the doublers, they are
terrible as the first pump spell, but
when combined with others, they can
deliver a value way higher than their
mana cost. The X pump spells serve
similar role. They're almost like
doublers as well. At the same time, fist
of fling. Again, early is not good, but
after you pump your commander and fire
off a huge draw spell, the fist can
easily pump for seven or eight while
replacing itself. Now, the blue ones are
the most interesting here. They do not
work with each other in multiples, but
as the first pump spell, they are
excellent value while providing some
extra utility, whether it's hexroof or
evasion. These are really nice to see in
the opening hand. Now that we have our
commander sitting at 7788, it's time to
look at part two, the best cards for
refilling our hands. And as you can see,
the only thing I looked for in these
extra spells is the amount of colored
costs. The lower the better. One, two is
acceptable, but any more than that is
not making the cut. Now, the nonext draw
spells are not worth playing with one
exception, the ones that can pay for
themselves. Tazar's Gambit is the worst
one here being free. And every other
draw spell here is actually a ritual
either ramping us with treasures or
untapping lands. And now that we have a
massive commander and just drew seven
cards, what we're going to look for in
those seven cards are the evasion spells
and finishers. And for evasion spells is
fairly straightforward. If Vagic doesn't
already have flying or trample from the
pump spells, we give it unblockable. And
here I chose the ones that can either be
used multiple times or replace
themselves. Throw in some finishers like
double strike or extra combat and you
probably have a dead opponent and also a
full grip of cards to kill the next one
and the next one. Yeah, just follow
these steps. Easy as 1, two, three,
four, five, six. But that's not it
because we need some protection spells
to round things out. Eventually, your
opponents learn about your deck through,
I don't know, dying and they know that
they have to remove magic at all costs.
So, we have eight spells here, mostly
giving hex proof. My favorite one here
is actually fleeting reflection. It's a
decent protection spell, but later on it
can be also used as a pump spell
depending on what your opponents have.
And lastly, to round things out with our
non-land cards, we have ramp. Starting
with some budget mana rocks, we only
play the two mana ones cuz we want to
drop it early and then have our
commander on turn three with protection
mana. And also, there are some
interesting lategame ones. The first one
being Brass's bounty. This was before
they discovered tapped treasures. So as
long as our commander is decently large,
this can easily be a ritual for four or
five mana. And also path the pyromancer.
Usually when we have a massive hand
after a draw spell, we are short on
mana. And just pay one more red to cast
this and suddenly you have a full grip
still. But eight more mana to use. And
make sure to insist that everyone does
the voting part even though it does
nothing. Never miss a chance for chaos.
And these are all the non-land cards.
The lands are actually super simple
because in this deck we don't want any
colorless land or any land that enters
tapped. That limits our option. We just
want manifixing. No utility, no strip
mine, no nothing. All the cheap
two-color lands. And pick a basic land
art that you like for a total of 37
lands. And that is our deck. The budget
is $50 and the play pattern is, I'd say,
fairly simple. Although sometimes you do
have to make decisions on when to pull
the trigger. For example, Valri, you can
cast them on turn three, but you have to
kind of assess the table. Do they have
removals? Is it safe? Do I cast Valdick
on turn three or turn four with one mana
for protection? Which opponent do I
attack first? The one who opened with a
soul ring? The one who's more explosive
later or the one who wins that my body
odor when we sat down? I mean, we've got
some decisions to make, but not too
many. And for $50, this deck has been
tearing my group apart. Bracket two,
bracket three, doesn't matter. If your
opponents fail to interact early, the
moment you get your first large Valdic
turn, it becomes more and more difficult
for them to stop you. And lastly, if you
do manage to open a VV and want to play
that instead, there are some changes to
make, but not too many. We replace the
two mana pump spells here with the one
mana ones and also add in some VV
specific cards like Curiosity. And
that's all for our deck tech. If you
like this content, please like and
subscribe for more. And if not, I'd love
a comment telling me what kind of
content you'd rather see. I'll do
anything. I'll see you later.